regularization
in machine learning
so our agenda on this one is fitting the
data
understanding linear regression bias and
variance
what is overfitting what is underfitting
and those are like the biggest things
right now in data science is overfitting
and underfitting
what does that mean and what is
regularization
and then we'll do a quick hands-on demo
to take a look at this
so fitting the data let's start with
fitting the data
and we talk about what is data fitting
it's a process of plotting
a series of data points and drawing the
best fit line
to understand the relationship between
the variables and this is what we called
data fitting and you can see here we
have a couple of lines we've drawn on
this graph
we're going to go in a little deeper on
there so we might have
in this case just the two dimensions we
have an efficiency of the car
and we have the distance traveled in 1
000 kilometers
and so what is data fitting well it's a
linear relationship
and a linear relationship very
specifically
linear means line the line used to
represent
the relationship is a straight line that
passes through the data points
and the variables have linear
relationship
linear regression so let's start with uh
how linear regression works a linear
regression
finds a line that best fits the data
point and gives a relationship between
the two variables
and so you can see here we have the
efficiency of the car
versus the distance traveled and you can
see this nice straight line drawn
through there
and when you talk about multiple
variables all you're doing is putting
this instead of a line that now becomes
a plane
it gets a little more complicated with
multiple variables but they all come
down to
this linear kind of drawing a line
through your data and finding
what fits the the data the best
and so we can consider an example let's
say that we want to find the
relationship between the temperature
outside versus the sales of ice cream
and so we start looking at that we're
looking at the how many ice cream cones
we're selling or how much money we sold
in ice cream
and we're looking at how warm it is
outside which would hopefully
draw a lot of people into the ice cream
store and suppose we have two lines
we're going to draw
l1 and l2 and we're going to kind of
guess which one we think
is the best fit and which claim to
describe the relationship between the
variables
and so first we find the square of the
distance between the line
l1 and each data point and add them all
and find the mean distance
and i want you to think about that when
we
square something if it's a negative or
positive number it no longer matters
because a minus
2 squared is 4 2 squared is 4. so we're
removing
what side of the line it's on and we're
just looking for the error
in this case the mean distance of each
of the little dotted lines you see here
this way of calculating the square of
the distance adding them and then taking
the mean is called
mean square error or loss function
and we talk about loss how far off are
we that's what we're really talking
about what did we miss
when we have a positive distance and a
negative distance and of course when we
square it it is neither
it just becomes a positive error and so
we take the mean
square error and a lot of times you'll
see it referred to as
mse if i look in the code and i'm going
through my python code and i see mse
i know that's a mean squared error and
we take all the dotted lines and we
calculate
this error we add them all together and
then we average it or find the means
and in this case they ran a demo on this
and it was uh
1127.27
for our l1 line now we find the loss
function for
line l2 in a similar fashion and we get
the mean square error
to be 6397
and it's computed the same way so maybe
you put this line just way outside the
data range and this is the error you get
by analyzing our results we find that
the loss function
or the mean square error is less for l1
than l2 hence l1 is the best
fit line this process
describes a lot of machine learning
processes
it was we're going to keep guessing and
get as close as we can to find the right
answer
we have to have some way to invite to
calculate this and figure out which
one's the best
and the mean square error is one of the
better fits to doing for doing this and
most commonly used
we really want to talk about bias and
variance
very important terms to know in machine
learning
and with linear regression
so bias bias occurs when an algorithm
has limited flexibility to learn from
data
variants defines the algorithm's
sensitivity to specific
sets of data let's start with bias and
variance you can see here we have
the two different setups
bias you can think is very generalized
where variance is
very specific and so we talk about bias
such models pay very little attention to
the training data and
over simplify the model therefore the
validation error or prediction error and
training error follow
similar trends and
uh with bias if you over simplify it so
much
you're going to miss your local
if if you have like a really good fit
you're going to miss it
you're you're going to just kind of
guess what the average is and that's
what your answer is going to be
with variance a model with a high
variance pays a lot of attention to
training data and does not generalize
therefore the validation error or
prediction error are far apart from each
other
such models always lead to a high error
on training and test data
as a bias does where variance such
models usually perform very well
on training data but have high error
rates on test data
and i want you to think about this when
we're talking about a bias
the error is going to be high both when
you're training it and you're testing it
why because we're just kind of getting
an
average we're not really fitting it
close
with variance we're fitting it so close
that the test data does really good it's
going to
nail it every time if you're doing
categorical testing that's a car that's
a truck that's a bicycle
but with variants suddenly a
truck has to have certain features and
it might have to be red
uh because you had so many red pictures
so if it has if it's an 18 wheeler it
has to be red
if it's blue then it has to be a bicycle
that's the kind of variance we're
talking about where it picks up on
something
and it cannot get the right answer
unless it gets a very specific data and
we see that so that as you're
testing it your models and you
programmed it you got to look for
how i trained it what is coming out and
if it's not if it's not looking good on
either bias or if it's not looking good
on the training
or on the test data then your
bias then you're biasing your data if it
really looks good
on the training data then that's going
to be your variance
you've over fitted the data and those
are very important things to know when
you are
building your models in regression of
any kind
or any kind of setup for predicting
so in dark games if all the data found a
particular pointer
this can be considered as a biased throw
and the player aims for the particular
score
for variance if all the darts fall on
different pointers and no two darts fall
on the same pointer
then this can be considered as a varied
throw and the player aims for various
scores
again the bias sums everything up in one
point kind of averages it together where
the variance really looks for the
individual
predictions coming out
so let's go ahead and talk about
overfitting uh when we talk about
overfitting it's a scenario where the
machine learning model tries to learn
from the details
along with the noise and the data tries
to fit each data point
on the curve uh you can see that
um if you plug in your coordinates
you're just going to get the
whatever is fitted every point on the
data stream there's no average there's
no
two points that might have that you know
why might have two different answers
because
if the wind blows a certain way um in
the efficiency of your car maybe you
have a headwind
so your car might alter how efficient it
is as it goes and so there's going to be
this variance on here
and this says no you can't have any
variance with you know the this is it's
going to be exactly this
it can't be any you can't be the same
speed or the same car and have a
slightly different
efficiency so
as the model has very less flexibility
it fails to predict
new data points and thus the model
rejects every new data point
during the prediction uh so you'll get
like a really high error on here
and so uh reasons for overfitting data
used for training is not cleaned and
contains
noise garbage values in it you can spend
so much time
cleaning your data and it's so important
it's so important that if you have
if you have some kind of something wrong
with the data coming in
it needs to be addressed whether it's a
source of the data maybe they
use in medical different measuring tools
so you now have to adjust for data that
came in from hospital a versus hospital
b
or even off of machine a and machine b
that's testing something and
those those numbers are coming in wrong
the model has a high variance again wind
is a good example
i was talking about that with the car
you may have a hundred tests but
because the wind's blowing it's all over
the place
size of training data used is not enough
so a small amount of data
is going to also cause this problem you
only have a few points and you try to
plot everything
the model is too complex this comes up a
lot
we put too many pieces together and how
they interact can't even be tracked
and so you have to go back back break it
up and find out actually what correlates
and what doesn't
so what is under fitting a scenario
where machine learning models can either
learn
the relationship between the data points
nor predict
or classify a new data point and you can
see here we have
our efficiency of our car and our line
drawn and it's just going to be way off
for both the training and the predicting
data
as the model doesn't fully learn the
patterns
it accepts every new data point during
the prediction
so instead of looking for a general
pattern we just kind of accept
everything
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage and values
again under fitting and overfitting same
issue you got to clean your data
the model has a high bias we've seen
this
in all kinds of things from uh
the mod the most common is the driving
cars to facial identification
or whatever it is the model itself when
they build it
might have a bias towards one thing and
this would be an underfitted
model would have that bias because it's
averaged it out so if you have
five people from india and 10 people
from
africa and 20 people from the u.s
you created a bias because it's looking
at the 20 people
and you only have a small amount of data
to work with
size of training data used is not enough
that goes with the size i was just
talking about so we have a model with a
high bias we have size of training data
used
it's not enough the model is too simple
again this is one straight line through
all the data when
it needs a slight shift to it for other
reasons
so what is a good fit uh a linear curve
that best fits the data is neither
overfitting or underfitting models but
is just
right and of course we have the nice
examples here where we have overfitting
lines going up and down every point is
trying to be include
gluted underfitting the line really is
off
from where the data is and then a good
fit is got to get rid of that minimize
that
error coming through regularization is
taking the guess work out
you're looking at this graph and you're
going oh which one is that really over
fit or is that under fit
that's pretty hard to tell so we talk
about regularization
regularization techniques are used to
calibrate the linear regression models
and to minimize the adjusted loss
function and prevent
overfitting or under fitting
so what that means in this case we're
going to go ahead and take a look at a
couple different things
we're going to look at regularization
which will start with a linear model
we'll look at the ridge
regularization and the lasso
regularization
and these models are just like just like
we did the
mlp the multi-layered positron in the sk
learn
module you could bring in the ridge
module
and you can bring in the lasso module
so when we talk about
ridge regression it modifies the
overfitted or underfitted models by
adding the penalty equivalent to the sum
of the squares of the magnitude of the
coefficients
and so we have a cost function equals
loss equals
lambda times the sum of w squared or the
absolute value of w depending on how
you're doing it
now remember we talked about error
whether we either square it or we
absolute value it
because that removes a plus or minus
sign on there and there's reasons to do
it either way but it is more common to
square the value
and then we have our in this case the
lambda is going to be the penalty for
the errors we've thrown in a greek
character for you just to confuse
everybody
and w is the slope of the curve of the
line
so we're going to look at this and we're
going to draw a line this is going to be
like a linear regression model so
if you had in sk learned you could
import just a standard linear regression
model
it would plot this line across whatever
data we're working on
and we look at this of course we're just
extrapolating this i know they use some
specific data
but you don't want to get into the
actual domain and so
for a linear regression line let's
consider two points that are on the line
and we'll go ahead and have a loss
equals zero
uh considering the two points on the
line we'll go ahead and do lambda equals
one
we'll set our w is going to be one point
four
then the cost function equals 0 plus 1
times 1.4 squared which equals 1.96
so really don't get caught up too much
in the math on this
other than understanding that this is
something that's very easy for a
computer
to calculate and if you ever see the
loss plus the
plus the lambda times w the sum of w
squared
and then let's say we have a ridge
regression line and it does this we go
ahead and plot it
and we do the calculations on the data
and for the ridge regression let's
assume a loss equals 0.3 squared plus
0.2 squared equals 0.13 so when they put
all the calculations through
of the two points we end up with a
0.0.622
so we've now had a linear regression
model we now had a ridge regression
model
and the ridge regression model plots a
little differently than the standard
linear regression model
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
ridge regression line
fits the model more accurately than the
linear regression line
and i find this true on a lot of data i
work with i'll end up using either the
ridge regression
model or the lasso mars regression model
for fitting especially dealing with a
lot of like
stock markets daily setup
they come out slightly better you get a
slightly better
fit and so we have our lasso we just
talked about lasso coming in here
and the cost function equals instead of
doing
a squared we're just going to do the
absolute value and so
if you remember this is where ridge
regression changes where's my ridge
regression model
uh we're squaring the value here
and if you look at this we're not
squaring the value we're just finding
the absolute value on here
and so the loss of this of the squared
individuals
and here is our lambda
symbol again penalty for errors and w
equals the slope of the curve
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
lasso regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and this is like i said i use these two
models a lot
uh the ridge and this is important this
is
this is kind of the meat of the matter
how do you know which one to use
some of it is you just do it a bunch of
times and then you figure it out
uh ridge regularization is useful when
we have
many variables with relatively smaller
data samples
the model does not encourage convergence
towards zero but is likely to make them
closer to zero and prevent
overfitting the lasser regularization
model
is preferred when we are fitting a
linear model with fewer variables
so in the la in the iris thing we had
four or five variables as you measure
the different leaf pieces
uh you might be doing the measurements
on the cancer project
which has 36 different variables um
so as we get down to the iris with four
variables
lasso lar will probably uh work pretty
good where you might use the ridge
regularization with more model with
if you have something significant larger
and it encourages the coefficients of
the variables to go towards zero because
of the shape of the constraint which is
an absolute
value and with any of this we want to go
ahead
and do a demo and lasso and ridge
regression
so let's take a look and see what that
looks like in our code and bring up
our jupiter notebook we'll start with
our imports
pandas is pd import numpy is np
import matplot library as plt
sklearn we're going to import our data
sets it's kind of more generic
we usually just import one data set
instead of all of them but you know
quick and dirty when you're putting some
of these together uh we have our sklearn
model selection we're going to import
our train test split for splitting our
data up
and then we'll bring in our linear
regression model
and we'll go ahead and run these just to
load them up and then load our data set
we're just talking about that
you could just have imported the load
boston and
boston data set in there instead of
loading all the data sets
and then once we've loaded our data set
we want to go ahead and take a look at
that data
and see what we got here let me just go
ahead and pop that down there
and go and run it
and so we've gone ahead and taken our
boston
data we're going to look we put it into
our pandas data frame
the boston data set and then the boston
columns
we want to see what's going on with them
we have our target
we have the house price etc and so our x
equals boston
um eye location
now remember in pandas the new updates
to pandas they want eye location
if you're going to pull data we used to
be able to leave this off
but it does something different it
creates a slice versus a direct
setup so make sure using that eye
location and the i the output so this is
all just
bringing our data together and we can
see here if we do
we print the boston panda's head
we can see here all of our different
aspects we're looking for
and if you're following the x and the y
the x is
everything except for the last column
where y is uh all the it's that's what
this means all the rows except for the
last column
and then y is all the rows but
just the last column so y is our house
price
and the x is the crimson industry
chas knox and all these other different
um statistics they've collected for
house sales in boston
there we go oops control ah
so we'll go ahead and split our data uh
x train and our x
test y train y test equals the train
test split which we imported
and we have our boston you could have
easily used the x and y
on here as opposed to boston eye
location
and we'll create our test size we're
going to take 25 percent of the data and
put it in as a test
and then we'll go ahead and run this uh
i need an extra drink there uh so we
have our
train and test and then of course the
print the train data shape
i love doing this kind of thing whenever
i'm working with this data
print out the shape make sure everything
looks correct
uh so that we have 127 by 13 and 127 by
one
379 by 13 they should match and if
they're if the
the data sets are not quite matching
then you know something's wrong and
you're going to get all those errors i
don't know how many times i've gone
through here
and it's dropped a row on one of them
and not on the other or something weird
has happened when i'm cleaning the data
this is pretty straightforward and
simple because the data comes in a nice
pre-package is all clean for you
so let's go ahead and apply apply the
multiple
linear regression model
and we'll call this lreg l reg
linear regression and we're going to go
ahead and fit that linear regression
model to
x train and y train then we'll generate
the prediction on the test set
so here's our l reg y predict
with our x test going into the
prediction
and let's calculate that mean square
error mse
i told you you'll see msc used a lot
people use it in variables and things
like that it's pretty common and we get
our mean squared error equals
this is just the basic formula we've
already been talking about what's the
difference
squared and then we look for the average
of that we'll go ahead and just run this
and you can see when we get through the
end of this we have our mean square
error on test
we have our total and then we have each
column coming down
and at this point unless you really know
the data you're working with
it's not going to mean a whole lot so if
it's in your domain you might be
know what you're looking at when you see
these kinds of numbers coming up
uh but if it's not it's just a bunch of
numbers and that's okay
at least that's okay for this demo uh
and then we're gonna go ahead and plot
these so we can see what's going on
and this is always kind of fun it's
always nice to have a nice visual of
what you're looking at
and you can see here we plot the
coefficient scores on here
and we the guys in the back did a great
job putting some pretty colors together
making it look nice
and setting up the columns you can see
here
uh your nox has like just a huge
coefficient
when i look at a table like this i look
for what has very little
different coefficients they're not using
a huge change in what has huge
changes and that flags you for all kinds
of things as you're working with the
data
but it depends so much on the domain
you're working with
these are great things though as just a
quick look to see what's going on with
your data and what you're looking for
and of course once we look at this now
our motive is to reduce the coefficient
score
so now we want to take these and and uh
bring them down as much as we can and
for that we're going to work with the
ridge regression on here
so let's start by going and we're going
to import our ridge model
the red regression from the sk learn
library or the scikit
and we're going to go ahead and train
the model so here's our ridge
r equals alpha equals one and i
mentioned that earlier
when i work with the ridge model you'll
see alpha equals one if you set alpha
equal to
zero that's a standard linear regression
model so you have alpha equals one two
three four and you usually use
1 2 or 3 4 and a standard integer on
there and we'll go ahead and fit
the ridge model on there with our x
train and our y train data
generate a prediction for that for our x
test
and we'll calculate the mean square
error
just like we did before this should all
look familiar
and we'll go ahead and print that out
and we'll look at the ridge coefficients
for our data and see what that looks
like
now if i jump up and down between these
two
you'll get a headache ah you'll still
see the knox value
let's just look at the knocks because
that was the biggest value it's a minus
nine here
and if we go back up here the nox value
is a minus 18.
so right off the bat i'm seeing a huge
change
in the biggest coefficient there
so if we're going to do that nice setup
we want to go ahead and just print it
and see what that looks like
here we go and we've set up our plot
subplots and again the team put together
some nice colors so it makes it look
good
we're doing an x bar based on the
columns
and our l regress coefficients color
equals color
x spine bottom and so forth so just put
together a nice little graph
and you're starting to see one this when
you compare this if you put on the same
graph as this one up here
this is up here minus 18 this is at
minus nine
and so this graph is half the size of
the graph above
the same thing with these values here
they might look
the same but they're actually all almost
half the value on here
and then finally you can do the same
thing for the lasso regression
this would all look very similar as far
as what we worked on before
and i'm just going to print that on here
and run it and again let's go up to
uh knox look where nox is it's all the
way down to
zero and if we look at our next biggest
coefficient it's
minus 0.8 and really here's our
22.7 let me go up here
um 16.7
and we go up here and we look at the
same number uh 16.69
so we look at this if i was running this
and doing a working on a project with
this
i would look at these numbers i start
with the 16.69
come down here and compare it to 16.78
six nine is better than seven eight uh
so from the very beginning we might
start looking at this first model for
overall
predicting but there's other factors
involved
we might know that the knocked value
is central and the other ones aren't
quite as good and so we might start
looking at
just certain setups like what is our
what is
this particular coefficient because it
might have a certain meaning to us
and so forth and so you look at all
those different items in there
again but the bottom dollar is our first
model did better than our other two
models
our mean square error on the test set um
continues to come down on this
so that concludes regularization in
machine learning
thank you for joining us for more
information please visit
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here